the Hollywood strike might be about to
get much much worse
for the studios welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so last week the DJ or the Director's
Guild of America actually struck an
agreement with the studios this was
considered a big coup for the studios as
they continue to argue with the writers
who are currently on strike and hoping
to nip a strike from the actors in the
bud as well who started negotiations
just last week the Actors Guild by the
way have already
a massive majority have voted that if a
deal isn't struck with the studios over
the next few weeks that they too will be
going on strike
but the studios looked like they'd
avoided a strike from the directors now
this had a couple of connotations
because basically on one level it gave a
blueprint for the other guilds for the
writers guilds the actors guilds to sort
of say look this is what we're given the
directors are you really going to ask
for more
come on let's beat out a deal something
around this it really did take the legs
out from under the writer's Guild and
the Actors Guild in their negotiations
because all of a sudden the students
could come back and say look the
directors are all right they're happy
why aren't you yeah I did actually argue
at the time when this news for the DGA
agreement came in
um because we're actually live at the
time that the problem that the Studios
have is that the issues the writers and
the directors have are very different
the directors got a nice New Cut of
money they had a deal or their residuals
Etc and they were reasonably happy or at
very least
the team negotiating work but I'm going
to come back to that in a minute
the problem is the writers have a very
different problem one of them being AI
which we'll talk about in a second and
one of them being the contractor they're
being forced to work to now over in the
United States they currently have an
agreement between all of these guilds
the actors the writers the directors Etc
and the studios and part of that
agreement is that they have agreed a
scale at minimum wage when you hear
actors saying oh I'm just working for
scale it basically means they're working
to this minimum wage now the writers
desperately want this bumped up the
actors and the directors do too but also
a lot of writers are being forced to do
these sort of like basically Zero Hour
contracts where they work for a late
night comedy show or something else and
they get paid basically by the hour now
they're saying that look either employ
me to do the job or don't but what a lot
of writers are being forced to do is
basically being paid by the hour and
then they can just be kicked tomorrow
now let's be honest none of us would
work in those circumstances so we can I
think understand why they're not very
happy about it another problem the
writers have though that the directors
really don't have and actually
apparently a lot of the directors have
basically said look this is a problem
for tomorrow we're not really interested
in this right now
is AI now we're seeing a lot more
Artificial Intelligence being used you
know it was a gimmick initially but now
it's actually being used to write
material and what the writers are saying
is look the way AI works is and I'm
going to use the Stargate example here
that when Brad Wright created a new
Stargate sg1 script I'm using AI that he
then read out with some of the actors on
the companion app what he did was he fed
a load of scripts from sg1 into the
algorithm and it spat out what it calls
an AI generated new script now what the
writers are saying is wait a second
that's my work that's gone into that
it's rejigged it and done some clever
reword and whatever but surely that
story is kind of based on what I wrote
isn't that copyright now I'm a little
bit torn on this problem I do actually
have some sympathy for the studios here
because legally I don't know how you
answer this problem now what the
directors basically agreed is the AI
cannot be used as a person
now that should really be common sense
but it can't so what they're saying is
the studios cannot use AI to generate
anything that you know could be classed
as a director's work now for me I would
just say the writers need to do the same
and they need to say basically you
cannot use AI to generate scripts done
now that should be straightforward but
there are some legal implications to
that and including sort of copyright law
that make it a little bit complicated
the residuals though are really a big
problem this is a problem that directors
have and the writers and a lot of the
problem comes from the streaming
services Netflix notoriously does not
like sharing information about viewing
figures they're really really bad at it
they don't like doing it and they get
out of it as much as they possibly can
the problem is a lot of the pay for the
writers is based on that thing called
residuals how often something they wrote
actually gets watched royalties if you
like
the deal that they currently have for
residuals is basically the streaming
service just tells them honest this is
how much it was watched and they they
get paid the writers are saying we want
way more transparency we want to
actually see the numbers numbers that
you keep refusing to show again if you
were in this situation I would argue
that you would not go to work and your
boss comes to you and says oh you got
your bonus this week but it's only three
pounds and next week it's going to be
300 pounds and you say why and they just
go don't you worry about it just just
trust me it's three pounds this week and
300 pounds next week you wouldn't go for
it you'd be annoyed and you'd want to
him to explain why you get so much one
weekend nothing the next so these are
the big problems that the Writers Guild
have and they can't seem to have an
agreement there are also some rumors to
suggest actually that the writer's Guild
Etc asked negotiating with people like
Netflix but Netflix isn't actually an
agreed sort of member or a unionized
member of The Guild so there is some
problems there when the negotiating
comes because they're kind of
negotiating with people that
shouldn't really legally be negotiated
with but and that's come from a source
that really is trying to understand this
problem and they've had to reiterate to
me repeatedly they're not 100 convinced
that is the case but that's what they're
being told but to get to the number why
this problem might get much much worse
so the directors their team that
negotiate with Studios have this
agreement
the problem is it then needs to go back
to the Director's Guild to be ratified
so they need to vote again to say yes we
agree with this deal that's been
so far agreed
the problem is we're hearing in this
Source it's a very close friend to the
channel and really really involved in
what's going on over there is saying
they're hearing voices that people are
voting no big names of voting no I've
spoken to one person in particular that
is a member of the Director's Guild and
they said look I don't care what deal
they've come up with until they get a
deal or something working with the
writers or at least start trying to come
up with a deal that compromises with the
writers I will vote no they are voting
in solidarity with the writers
I actually think the actors are doing
exactly the same at the moment where
there's something 97 or something voted
that they will strike if a deal isn't
done the studios are in a real problem
right now because they thought they've
got a big coup with getting the
directors on board they thought that was
their way in but now it looks like even
though they might have got some sort of
deal with the people there from the
Director's Guild the people they're
actually negotiating but the problem is
the actual people that matter the
members of The Guild are going to say no
now this may just be a loud minority
shouting no no no and actually you know
maybe it'll go the other way but at the
moment it's looking like the directors
might not have a deal and if they don't
then the studios really do have nothing
and they really are gonna have to try to
think of something to resolve this
problem why is this taking so longer a
lot of streaming services and a lot of
studios are under massive financial
problems right now we keep talking about
this on this channel Paramount massive
debt
Amazon actually have some serious
Financial issues because they over
expanded during the covid crisis and
then when things went back to normal
they all of a sudden went oh what people
aren't just sat at home buying stuff for
fire and website anymore that doesn't
make sense Disney plus is losing
hundreds of millions of dollars every
week these companies are having to
restructure and the last thing in the
world they want to do is agree to having
to pay the writers the directors and the
actors significantly higher wages it is
the wrong time for them now I say boohoo
but
there is a serious issue here that they
need to compromise something that makes
sense for both because what you can't do
is for Disney to say yeah okay we'll pay
you a bit more but then legendary
pictures goes out of business because
they can't afford to pay the agreement
so there needs to be a compromise that
works for everybody yes writers need to
be able to make a living actors and
directors do too because remembering
we're not talking about the writers and
the directors and the actors that you
know their name you're talking about the
95 of the others that you don't
these people need to be able to make a
living because we want that
entertainment guys I'd love to know what
you think they'll get in the comments
and tell me is this a fight that they
need to win because at the end of the
day people need to be able to feed their
kids and pay their bills right
does there need to be a compromise that
does work for everybody here I'd love to
know exactly what you think so get in
the comments if you are new to the
channel like subscribe you know what to
do
um so you never miss any of our new
videos make sure you hit that Bell also
go to patreon.com forward slash
Sidetrack where most of our new videos
air first and you get to see them
without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]